told you about
the Metro going and correcting on the
practice telling the pope to you know
behave different okay he also told
Einstein explicitly long time ago right
I mean that why do you throw away
because why do you say the Cosmetic
constant cannot be there it's not an
aesthetic question see the Aesthetics
again I mean you and I it's not an
aesthetic practice it's an observational
question it's either there it's not
there and we see today anyway
but that is not accepted in the in the
internal world I mean you couldn't go
and you know in a conference and say or
you know
that was wrong
so I think that this idea that there is
absolute thing and you arrive there and
then that is static that I find not very
pleasant and not not very
time to think of not not very useful
attitude uh not you know it's a it's a
attitude which is self-limiting I think
well scientists don't have that attitude
so that is good about it but there is
this problem you know you go and talk to
these people and they they want to
dismiss science at once and you talk to
scientists and they want to dismiss uh
anything the world has been always gone
the deep end
but I mean I just close your eyes and
there's a reality there huge reality
that you are dealing with all the time
and somehow that it is not interesting
is a this is a
and so I
sometime in 80s I thought that is really
important that you know that
what is the nature of reality and each
of them somehow think that well I can
just extending keep extending and then
we will cover everything and you don't
know what we can already extended and
they're like you know science keeps
progressing and progressing and
progressing and you know just we just
reached it no
we don't know right I mean if I take
infinite time to even describe the
external world we don't know that is
going to happen in the finite amount of
time would make continuous progress and
sure rate and there's no question it's
deeply valuable it's beautiful when you
discover something new I said there's no
question about it
but then so so therefore I came up with
this idea that maybe you know reality is
perhaps if you at all want to model it
uh however incomplete that may be maybe
maybe next model by a manifold picture
as I was mentioning to you the other day
it can be more complicated manifold but
the simplest example would be just a
two-dimensional sphere the surface of a
ball
and we know from the globe you know from
the earth sort of saying looking at the
maps and such thing in the globe that if
you try to project it down
on a plane then you have to do the
projected match you can take this North
Pole and that project each point of the
globe
draw a straight line and then we get a
get a faithful picture of everything but
the North Pole on a pit it's a very
distorted picture it's not the second
problem
so it's another it doesn't some areas
look much bigger than they really are
and so on so but you get that picture
but you cannot cover the whole the whole
sphere with a single chart single
coordinate system single X and Y thing
and so I felt that maybe that is that is
true with reality that there is internal
world and there is an external world
and the best case may be that you know
you can try to cover more and more of
the internal and more and more of the
external world and they will give you
some some charts to say and then the
Deep question is going to be about the
overlap functions because that is where
the
the chart transitions yeah the the key
thing about manifold lies right I mean
there's this compatibility of the two
charts compatibility to coordinate
system that they develop we can now
North Pole chart you can have salt pole
chart and around the equator there are
compatibility condition that should be
satisfied in other words the same
phenomena can be looked at in two
different ways and they should be
compatible you just watched a clip from
the theories of everything channel for
the full video and all its magnificence
then click here and if you'd like to see
more then subscribe enjoy